[Music]
straight ahead on lawn crime daily
a federal jury deliberates the fate of
three ex-police officers charged in the
death of george floyd just talking to
people in the community a lot of them
feel like derek chovin was the killer
and there's a lot of mixed feelings
about the role that these officers
played plus the verdict appears to be
proper order madam clerk a verdict is
reached in the daytona beach serial
killer trial and prosecutors recount the
moments leading up to the deadly oxford
high school shooting his word that he
uses is that he wants to torture
those birds but first hear from both
sides as opening statements are
presented in the trial of ex-louisville
officer brett hankerson this is not a
case
to decide
who is
responsible
for the death of rihanna taylor brett
hankerson was justified in what he did
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
and welcome everybody to long prime
daily i'm jesse weber in for brian
buckmeyer who's in kentucky covering the
trial connected to the death of briana
taylor i'm joined as always by co-host
terry austin nearly two years after the
shooting death of brianna taylor opening
statements are presented in louisville
as ex-officer brett hankinson stands
trial hankerson is not charged in the
killing of briana taylor but instead
faces charges of wanton endangerment for
firing shots through taylor's apartment
into a unit behind hers in march of 2020
three officers executed a no knock
warrant to taylor's apartment her
boyfriend believing the officers were
intruder intruders fired shots at them
the officers fired back and taylor was
killed in that crossfire ex-louisville
officer john mattingly who assisted
hankinson in the raid was also shot
during opening statements prosecutors
reminded jurors the case was not about
the death of briana taylor but instead
the danger that the defendant put her
neighbors in
this is not a case
to decide who is
responsible
for the death of brianna taylor this is
not a case about the louisville metro
police department
as far as whether or not there
needs to be reform
or more support for officers who put
their lives on the line every day this
is a case about the actions of brett
hankerson
on the night of march
12 march 13
because it started about midnight
2020.
and about as you heard
the circumstances
under which
he acted
during the defense's opening statement
attorney stu mathews told jurors the no
knock warrant was ill-prepared but that
hankerson acted appropriately
nobody thought there would be any danger
there and so i think that somebody
dropped the ball and there wasn't as
much preparation done in the search of
her place which is what
led up to
the shooting of john mattingly and
ultimately to detective hankinson firing
his rounds through her apartment that
went into apartment three
all of that happened instantaneously all
together and i think ladies and
gentlemen after you've heard all the
evidence you're going to determine that
brett hankerson was justified in what he
did and everything he did on that scene
out there
before during and after the shooting
occurred
was logical was reasonable was justified
and made total sense
long crime daily host brian buckmeyer
was inside the courtroom for opening
statements and he joins us now live in
louisville kentucky for the latest
developments brian
jesse day one of kentucky vs brent
hankinson has been eventful even before
court began session the sister of briana
taylor was actually asked to leave the
courtroom for wearing a sweater that
said arrest the cops who killed beyond
brianna taylor i spoke with janaya
palmer afterwards she's the maternal
sister of brianna taylor she says she
was wearing the sweater to demand
justice for her late sister but that she
was told the outfit was inappropriate
for the courtroom because it could cause
bias for the jurors she also tells me
she walked out of the courtroom after
the lunch break because she didn't feel
the prosecution was doing a good job
i left because i just feel like
everything they're in they're saying
they're running around in circles about
what really happened instead of actually
like really presenting while they're
there y'all there because brent shot
through some walls
present like present pertaining to that
quit pretending pertaining to that night
if you're not actually charging her for
brianna's murder
and
i guess the question is like how do you
feel the prosecution's doing in this
case terrible
i don't feel like they're doing exactly
what they could be doing
taylor's sister says she will be back in
the courtroom to see how the trial plays
out jesse
joining us today is co-host terry austin
and criminal defense attorney adam konta
it's good to see everybody here adam
we'll start with you prosecutors made it
very clear this case is not about the
death of brianna taylor and the question
that a lot of us are still wondering is
why have no been no charge has been
filed on that front
because they don't know how to get past
the burden of proving it
it's going to be an impossible case to
prove this was never going to be a case
that was going to be solved in a court
of criminal law this is always going to
be a civil matter for brianna taylor's
family you know whether we think uh
something wrong happened in that
no-knock warrant
that night whether we know something
wrong happened it doesn't really
matter for her family unfortunately
because i don't think they
have enough to prove it beyond a
reasonable doubt they would they would
walk away from that emotionally empty
now brian you're on the ground in
louisville what do you think of the
trial so far what is the atmosphere like
paint a picture for us
yeah so i think brianna taylor's sister
said it best it's somewhat disappointing
i understand brianna taylor isn't the
focus of this case she's not the victim
here but so far all i'm seeing is a long
drawn-out presser to explain that the
warrant was valid and that officers did
well but i'm waiting to see the
recklessness of brett hankinson why are
we here and that seems to be on the back
burner uh as opposed to everything else
you know it's quite a remarkable
statement that his sister made that
brianna teller's sister made as well you
know terry we keep looking at brian
hankinson and the question is is he
going to take the stand early reports
are that he plans to do so do you think
he's going to help his case if he
actually testifies about what happened
jesse i do think he's going to help his
case and as a matter of fact i don't
think he has a choice i think he has to
get on that stand we've already seen
some other detectives on the stand and i
think he's going to have to give his
perspective so that the jury understands
what was in his mind what was he
thinking the defense has said it is so
chaotic why was it chaotic what did you
do to try to calm that seat down what
exactly were your intentions he has said
he was trying to
help and save his colleagues and if
that's the case what made him think that
he had to do that going to say probably
that he saw the fire from the gun and he
didn't have a choice and we already know
mattingly was actually shot so i think
that his getting on the stand is going
to help his case i think the three is
going to probably relate to him because
so far it does seem as though this is a
valid warrant they went there with the
understanding there might be contraband
there and they in fact you know at least
not ram the door down and perhaps he was
acting to make sure that his whole
colleague and everyone else was safe and
that's probably what will happen it'll
be fascinating to see what he says on
the stand brian great reporting as
always thank you still ahead on long
crime daily a verdict is in for the
so-called daytona beach serial killer
but first we're learning more about the
grisly details and plans made by accused
oxford high school shooter
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to
youtubetv today and then locate lawn
crime in the channel guide and for only
1.99 a month you can add the network to
your bundle watch lawn crime every day
with youtube tv we put you in the jury
box
[Music]
and welcome back everybody a judge will
soon decide whether accused high school
shooter ethan crumbly will be
transferred to a children's facility as
he awaits trial at a hearing on tuesday
defense attorneys argued that 15 year
old crumbly should be relocated to a
children's village right now he's being
held at the oakland county jail for
adults under constant supervision
crumbly faces multiple charges including
terrorism causing death first degree
murder and assault with intent to murder
for the oxford high school shooting in
november of last year officials say
crumbly opened fire at the school
killing four students and injuring eight
others prosecutors say that his parents
jennifer and james crumbly ignored
warning signs leading up to the shooting
and they now face four counts of
involuntary manslaughter while defense
attorneys moved for a relocation at
tuesday's hearing prosecutors argue that
crumbly is much more sophisticated than
the at-risk juveniles at the children's
village therefore putting them at risk
prosecutors they then laid out harrowing
evidence that the shooting was
premeditated
he writes in depth in his journal about
his desire to stalk rape and kill a
fellow classmate
his plans for the school shooting what
he'll do how he'll do it who he will
kill first how he's putting in his
planet to action and among those steps
is enlisting his own father to get him a
nine millimeter gun because that
particular weapon is more desirable to
maximize the number of kills that he can
get
he also speaks of how he'll be
remembered
november 30th 2021 was not an isolated
incident for this defendant this is
someone who wants to be remembered and
he has contemplated how he wants to be
remembered not as someone who made a
positive impact on society not someone
who brought something
good or meaningful to the table but he
wants to be compared to the likes of
hitler or dahmer or the parkland school
shooter
now the defense has indicated that
crumbly will argue an insanity defense
in the case the trial judge will make a
ruling on the relocation motion by next
week so i'm back here with terry austin
and adam kanta adam prosecutors also
made note of videos that crumbly made
before the shooting where it's showing
him torturing birds i mean is that
something that we could expect to see at
trial is that evidence is strong for the
prosecution as it may seem
yeah i mean
killing animals is one of those sort of
classic uh signs of serious mental
illness of being maybe a sociopath of
having uh having a person having the
ability to commit these types of acts uh
so i think a lot of this
you know it's gonna be questionable if
they do an insanity defense then you're
putting his mental state squarely in
question and you have the burden of
proving that he rises to that level as
the defense uh so then that stuff has to
come you have to say hey look from the
very beginning this kid was showing
signs he needed help and nobody reached
out and gave him help so they're going
to have to put all that in if they want
to meet the very very high bar
of an insanity defense and that very
high bar terry what's the likelihood of
insanity being a successful defense here
i actually think they're not going to
win that defense it's an affirmative
defense in michigan and they're going to
have to show that he lacked the capacity
to appreciate the wrongfulness of his
conduct and even though he has shown all
of these signs that he is not mentally
stable i don't think they're going to
know that he didn't know what he was
doing was absolutely wrong the defense
has to prove that by at least
of the evidence and i don't think the
jury is going to go for that type of
defense this was a heinous crime
killed multiple people he has no remorse
and i think the jury is going to do all
that they can find that he
yeah so the sad case disturbing case to
say the very least we're going to
continue to follow it coming up on long
crime daily the fate of three
ex-minnesota police officers is now in
the hands of a federal jury plus after
only hours of deliberation a verdict is
reached in the trial of the so-called
daytona beach serial killer that's next
[Music]
and welcome back a florida jury reaches
a verdict in the case of the so-called
daytona beach serial killer prosecutors
argued that robert hayes shot and killed
laquita gunther julie green and awana
patton between 2005 and 2006. officials
say the three women were sex workers in
the daytona beach area hayes was linked
to the killings after another woman was
murdered in 2016 in west palm beach
prosecutors say that that victim rachel
bay was also a sex worker throughout its
case the prosecution focused on the dna
found on the first three victims the
defense said that holes in the
prosecution's case didn't prove that
hayes was the one responsible well after
just nine hours of deliberation a jury
reached a verdict on all charges
we the jury find the defendant robert
tyrone hayes as follows count one first
degree premeditated murder of laquita
gunther section one guilty of
first-degree murder count two first
degree premeditated murder of julie
greene section one guilty of first
degree premeditated murder count three
first degree premeditated murder of
iowano patton
guilty
guilty of first degree premeditated
murder
hayes guilty verdicts mean that he now
faces the death penalty hayes is due
back in court next monday for the
penalty phase of this case and will also
be tried at a later date for the murder
of rachel bay okay so adam you know
there were no eyewitnesses in this case
why do you think the prosecution was
just able to prove this case on
circumstantial evidence alone
well there was circumstantial evidence
but the dna was just so much here i mean
the fact that these were all sex workers
they all had a similar sort of uh they
had a similar
bio they had a similar modus that they
were working out there he was in college
nearby and the dna was so much there was
really there was nothing else
unfortunately for him that made sense
you know as i watched this trial i kept
wondering like what's what's the defense
going to be honestly and i think it just
it never came you know and so that's why
we're here where we are and the jury
made pretty quick work of it right for a
jury to do this that fast is sort of
stunning yeah and it's also his alleged
lies and the the cell phone evidence
it's really important but you know i am
curious do you think he's going to
receive the death penalty as another
murder trial lined up what do you think
the odds are that he gets death here
you know i've been surprised by florida
before i mean i feel like i say that
once a week but uh you know you never
know what they're gonna do
to me this seems like a case that would
rise to the level of death penalty
regardless if i personally don't believe
in it uh
so i think it does meet that criteria of
that extra level of of just heinousness
and a heinous crime
but you know they've taken florida looks
at these things in a specific way and
sometimes juries just don't see the
mitigating factors that would get you
there i think there is though i think it
will get there yeah and you know his
defense team is definitely going to
focus on mental health as a kind of
mitigating factor so we'll see which way
it ultimately ends up
when we come back the trial for the
death of george floyd we sit down with a
local reporter covering the trial at the
federal courthouse what he says could
happen as jurors move into deliberation
and welcome back everybody wednesday
marks the two-year anniversary of the
death of ahmad arbury the anniversary
comes just one day after the three men
convicted in his murder were found
guilty of federal hate crimes the
unanimous verdict for travis mcmichael
gregory mcmichael and william roddy
bryant was reached after just four hours
of deliberation the defendants were
charged with interference with rights
which is a hate crime and attempted
kidnapping all three men already faced
life in prison stemming from the georgia
state trial that we covered here on the
network brian is eligible for parole
after 30 years the mcmichaels will serve
20 years on top of their life sentences
and a federal judge ruled a sentencing
hearing will be scheduled after
pre-sentencing reports are filed
the fate of three ex-minnesota police
officers is now in the hands of the jury
as they face federal child charges in
connection to the death of george floyd
prosecutors say ex-cops two tao thomas
lane and jay alexander king deprived
george floyd of his rights back in may
of 2020 with all three failing to
provide him medical aid and king and tau
also for failing to intervene when
ex-cop derrick chauvin knelt on floyd's
neck all three defendants took the stand
for the defense each saying they
believed veteran officer chauvin had the
situation under control and they
deferred all decisions to him last year
chauvin was convicted in floyd's murder
in state court and he's pleaded guilty
to violating floyd's civil rights in
federal court in closing arguments on
tuesday prosecutors said all three
officers knew chauvin was using
unreasonable force but refused to step
in defense attorneys countered saying
that none of the defendants intended to
hurt floyd but were rookie officers
lacking experience long crime network
spoke with k-11 reporter lou regoose
reporting from the federal courthouse
since opening statements and he told us
a wide range of sentences could be
handed down if a jury convicts the
defendants
my sources that work their entire
careers in the federal courts
calculating these guys even having no
criminal history
they think the guidelines show something
like 30 years to life
however judge magnussen has a lot more
discretion and can go below the
guidelines and i think everybody agrees
there's there's no way that if they're
guilty that he even comes close to what
they're going to give derek show and he
did a plea bargain in federal court to
this charge and he'll receive a sentence
between 20 and 25 years when it's
finally handed down there's been a lot
of objections a lot of sustained
objections throughout this trial you
know in comparison to other cases i've
covered and so
the judge very well could take it into
his own hands you know in sentencing and
and
you know it could give them
as little as no time to as much as a few
years if they're convicted
so so adam here's the thing that gets me
you know the jury has to decide the fate
of three separate defendants how does
that work exactly i mean what are the
odds that separate verdicts are reached
for each of them and they look at each
defendant separately
well i think the odds that there's going
to be separate verdicts is fairly
unlikely i think their conduct you know
when you have co-defendants uh the
conduct is is it similar is it different
sometimes you blame your co-defendants
so even though you're sitting at the
same table you're actually saying well
they're they're much more responsible
than i am here it's a pretty united
front right all three of them are
accused of not doing anything and all
three of them are saying yeah but look
it was officer shovin it was his show
and so we were just kind of following
along
so i think in this particular case it
makes sense they're sitting at the same
table and it makes sense that the jury
is deliberating them all together even
though they're looking at the evidence
maybe separately for each of them you
know the conduct is so similar and the
charges are so similar for all of them
uh then in this situation i think it's
it's totally logical that they're all
looking at the same outcome and i think
we'll probably get the same verdict see
it was one thing for chauvin to be
convicted i am very curious to see what
the verdicts are for these former
officers if they are convicted how is
that going to affect the culture of
policing how is that going to change
things
that's a really good question jesse and
that's you know it worries me as someone
who thinks there needs to be tremendous
amounts of police reform and i'm so glad
we're having the conversation about it
but what we're doing in this particular
case you're looking at two cops who were
rookies and they didn't intervene in a
situation that they should have no doubt
but if you convict these guys of this
crime right now what message are you
sending to anyone out there who's
thinking hey do i want to become a
police officer because i wouldn't do it
i wouldn't want to become a police
officer knowing that one mistake on my
first day on the job one of my first
days on the job could lead to the rest
of my life in prison when my intentions
were purely noble this is a really fine
line we as a society are dancing on
right now so i'll be really curious to
see how it does effect and it's not just
you know what chauvin did but if you
stand by look what happens adam conte
thank you so much thanks for joining us
here on long crime daily we're gonna see
you next time as we discuss justice in
america
[Music]
you